I gotta tell you you actually posted a
meme you said the 2023 energy is that
little dancer that have you been
channeling that this year so far oh yeah
absolutely I'm channeling my joy that's
right I mean there's a lot to celebrate
don't you think life is is is a
celebration right you know especially at
this point in our lives
a project like this because I know you
really put your Blood Sweat and Tears
into the woman King and so now to be
here receiving the chairman award I mean
do you feel like all that time in the
gym was worth it
well I felt it was worth it when I got
on the soil in South Africa and that red
dirt and to be with Tucson Lashana and
Sheila and all the beautiful Jamie's and
the Adrians and you know I felt it was
worth it then when you see your dream
and you see all your hard work come to
fruition and then to present it to the
world that was towards the middle of the
race but we saw it from the beginning
and you know I've had a beautiful career
of course but
autonomy and agency has been elusive to
me having control of my work and my
voice has been elusive oh so that makes
this even more special I'm sure a true
passion project huh yeah yeah what was
your reaction when you first saw her up
there as the woman King well I mean I
was just proud I mean it was a fruition
of seven years of hard work of you know
allowing Viola to have the opportunity
to get the kind of role she wanted to to
play to portray and so it was a
beautiful thing you know it was awesome
well we've seen you at the Golden Globes
next so until then enjoy
foreign